i have waited for this to happen since
july 3rd 2020 two years and 67 chapters
ago where ichiro oda first introduced us
to yamato son of kaido self-declared
kozuki odin and one of the most fun and
awesome characters in all of one piece
and now with the release of chapter 1051
i'm gonna take a real risk and declare
that it is now official that yamato is
going to be the 11th straw hat that will
join luffy's quest to become king of the
pirates and find the one piece i've been
praying for this to happen for so long
and just couldn't help but jumping
around the room grinning when yamato
finally introduced herself to the rest
of the straw hat crew also just to get
it out of the way i will refer to yamato
as a she in this video because i
personally think yamato isn't
identifying herself as a man like kiko
or izodu as a woman but rather she wants
to be odin for what he represented and
stood for i think a man that gave her
hopes strength and courage in a lonely
and painful childhood that she embraced
as a sort of mental shield to not break
under kaido's tyranny being odin for
yamato seems to be a value and
personality based thing to me it's
something that she will actually have to
learn to drop as she will go and travel
with the straw hats to accept herself
and her own strength trying to be
someone else i think is actually a real
character flaw that oda sensei actively
gave her that she will need to overcome
because yamato has as we know already an
incredibly strong will and personality
of her own that is quite unique and
distinct from odin if anything i think
her real self is a lot closer to luffy
actually i think and apart from odin's
ideology i personally think she very
clearly embraces her femininity and so i
will refer to her as she at least until
we get any other evidence to the
contrary i hope that makes sense but
with uh that out of the way here's why i
think that yamato is and always has been
the perfect candidate to join the straw
hat crew and how she will make the straw
hats journey even more enjoyable to
follow than it already is i think it's
really really easy to see that oda
sensei had a lot of fun developing and
writing yamato into the story i like to
think that the idea for this character
has been lying around ready somewhere in
his draw for a long long time where he
was just itching to finally reveal her
now even though character writing is oda
sensei's absolute supreme discipline
yamato stood out as something special to
me right from the start with every
single chapter and every single panel
she was in we learned so much about her
personality her fears and hopes and what
she stands and fights for her dream is
not only connected to luffy it literally
is traveling with the straw hats and
seeing the real world outside wono for
the very first time with her own eyes
you know how luffy liberated every
single straw hat that joined the crew
from some sort of prison either literal
or mental zorro from the navy base nami
from arlong sanji from his sense of
worthlessness broke from his loneliness
jimby from freaking impul down and he
liberates yamato from both her physical
chains that had forced her to stay on
monophysically but also from her
father's tyrannical rule alongside with
the other people of wano what i'm
probably most excited about is the
dynamic that yamato will undoubtedly
bring to the crew overall let me know if
you feel the same way but to me her
character brings back a ton of pre-time
skip energy a true powerhouse with the
same nativity and enthusiasm of early
luffy everything she sees will be new
and awesome to her seeing the sunny
riding on it on the ocean meeting new
people fighting enemies outside of mono
i can absolutely see yamato in true odin
fashion running out with a grin
attacking random pirate ships and just
like luffy talking to and exploring
everyone and everything she sees
just think how awesome her chemistry
with the crew will be even though she's
arguably one of the most powerful
characters in the story she will be
eager to see chopper create medicine be
the ultimate audience for all of usopp's
lies help robin with the pony glyphs
through odin's diary be a true sparring
partner for zorro sanji and brook of
course already love her anyways and i
don't really see how she wouldn't get
along with nami and so i really like to
think that yamato will refresh all of
our own experiences with the crew as
well so yeah chemistry is the most
important factor for me personally when
it comes to any new straw hat but of
course power plays a real role as well
but do we
even need to talk about that
yamato was going head to head with kaido
alone for quite a while while luffy was
out like i really don't want to rank her
among the straw hats maybe zoro is
stronger maybe she is but i'm not sure
anyone beside luffy would have been able
to do that and so with yamato we
basically got a mini kaido joining the
crew she has been trained by the yonko
knows all his moves with his club can
use advanced conquest hockey and will be
the third zone fruit to join the crew
with her mythical imo inonomi that even
gives her ice powers i mean mini aokiji
on top as well i guess
not only does yamato have a ton of room
to grow and develop as a person
traveling with luffy and kobe as i
talked about earlier but there's still
quite a lot of unclear things about who
she really is as far as we know she does
in fact seem to be kaido's actual child
but we don't know why kaido had a kitten
to begin with and who yamato's mother
might be and so really no matter from
what angle i'm looking at this i
couldn't think of anyone better to
become part of the crew of a new emperor
that will be an invaluable asset in the
terrifying and dangerous fights and
trials that are yet to come i'm also
really interested what yamato's bounty's
gonna be once the new wanted posters
arrive it will definitely be more than
mine my current one is 59 million 100
berries for each of you who is
subscribed so our first priority right
now as a crew together is to overtake at
least this terrible man here treble who
despite his constantly running nose
somehow has a 99 million buried bounty
on his head so please help me overtake
him by subscribing also i absolutely
love tama's reaction to yamato telling
the crew that she will sail with them
look at this panel it would be
absolutely awesome honestly to have her
on board as well after all she and
yamato both hoped to join ace one day
and thomas flashback during this chapter
made the entire thing even more
emotional than it already was i mean we
already got toko's memories of yasu and
their poverty growing up and now thomas
hits just as hard if not harder we see
her losing her parents and trying to
make a living selling the same hats that
she showed ace how to make at least she
had her puppy komainu by her side which
does make the entire thing somewhat more
bearable to read until finally tengoyama
steps in to take her in i'm actually
still pretty convinced that he will turn
out to be someone who we've seen before
somewhere one of the former daimyos or
some other important person from the
past i'm also really curious to find out
who he is and whether that entire tengu
thing with the mask and the wings is a
fashion choice or a devil fruit power
maybe but as if ecstasy about yamato and
sadness and relief for tama weren't
enough for my poor heart in one chapter
oda sensei had to throw in awe and shock
as well because finally finally finally
we get to see momo's 28 year old self
and oh boy
momo in the shogun's kimono with the
giant kazuki crest flowing long black
hair and a determined look on his face
is so so much more than what i ever
expected he looks absolutely badass
there's no other way of saying it really
is there like comparing this kid's mom
man giving a fierce speech to his people
comparing that to the mobile we first
met on punk hazards like momo had by far
the most underrated character arc
throughout all of juana what say his
change has been absolutely incredible
and his reunion with his sister who also
has suffered through so so much in the
past is truly heartwarming to see here
as well honestly after the last two
chapters did leave the end of the raid
feel a bit unresolved and open seeing
momo like this seeing tama and toko
being freed from their pain and everyone
cheering it felt like an immensely
satisfactory ending to the battle even
if there might still be more fighting to
be done in wano when the arc does still
seem far from over yet i think but most
importantly we now have yamato my
personal best girl in one piece finally
join the ranks of the crew giving the
straw hats three powerful zone devil
fruit users and if you want to know
whether luffy yamato and chopper are
even amongst the best 5 zone devil
fruits you really shouldn't skip this
video right here